le choc a été d'une rare violence en
témoigne aussi l'arbre déracinée il a
permis au bus d'être stoppé dans son
élan la conductrice et la plus gravement
touchée elle a été désincarcéerée et
héliportée à l'hôpital de Dijon les
enseignants et les accompagnateurs ont
immédiatement pris en charge les enfants
seuls deux d'entre eux ont légèrement
été blessés et transportés à l'hôpital
de Châtillon l'évacuation des enfants
s'est passé dans le calme et de façon
assez assez facile avec l'aide et les
premiers intervenants qui étaient les
enseignants et les accompagnants qui
étaient dans ce bus quand à la
conductrice a été un peu plus compliqué
ça nécessite une désincarcération de la
part des services de secours pour ce qui
est du dépannage et bien c'est du
matériel lourd avec des grues
spécifiques pour relever le bus et puis
le remettre sur la chaussée avant de
pouvoir le remorquer les enfants
revenaient de la piscine lorsque
l'accident s'est produit pour François
sauvadep président du conseil
départemental de Côte-d'Or les consignes
de sécurité à l'intérieur du bus ont été
respecter nous allons vraiment éviter le
pire d'abord parce que tous les enfants
portaient leur ceinture de sécurité et
ça vous le savez la sécurité et notre
priorité d'ailleurs tous les bus de
Côte-d'Or pour des ceintures et je veux
faire un rappel aujourd'hui quand les
enfants montent dans les bus le bus ne
doit pas démarrer si tous les enfants
n'ont pas la ceinture de sécurité la
départementale 901 en direction de
communi sur scène a été coupée dans les
deux sens pendant près de 5 heures
l'enquête se poursuit pour déterminer
les circonstances exactes de l'accident